so here you have four colors okay let's
explore this in a little more honest
demand way we'll start with something
simple y equals it's frustrating so
these are all the numbers given B what
does y equal x plus 3 looks like well we
just came out the topic it's a straight
line in center add 3 and negative 3
ok there's the function study you can
call it labeling it let's think about
donated range where does this graph
exist so domain for X values is there
any mech X Ally where it stops for it
like I can't go there's not allowed
no you can just keep on going that's why
our errors this side and this side right
goes on forever so remember how it
reduced reduced our little symbol here I
can say all real values of X might save
myself writing the word real but because
this is afraid the message you should
say very very frequently they get sick
of either writing something that short
so they introduce a new symbol it looks
weird but I'll explain it in a second so
the way that you read this is X is an
element that's that's why it looks like
a be of the real number cell but what it
means is all your values of X X can be
any real number you like all real values
of x is you know if you're not too keen
on the weird funky Greek notation then
just say the sentence that was donated
to relook you're horrible what about
vertically where did the graph exist up
and down it keeps going just like it
does for the XS so in this case I could
say all real values of Y can submit up
and down but I'm going to be shaped like
a mathematician and honestly say that ok
so that's a really simple relation I
worked on uh who wondered was it you
surely said that and if you're going to
be with you yeah now this is a relation
right look you see it looks just like an
equation it's got two variable
and it indicated a relationship between
the two let's just reverse them for that
would I need to draw a bunch of that you
know what sine X looks like again I pose
the same question when I figure out the
domain where is this relation to find
what X values can take on enter anything
exonic alike look see it goes on forever
periodically repeats and repeats and
repeats so I'm going to say X can be any
of those real numbers but when I go to
add to the question of rage it becomes a
little more tricky because you can't
just put in any Y value you like the
graph constantly exists anywhere up the
down you like it's locked in between
negative 1 and 1 and you'll notice it's
inclusive they'll get to what does it
and does they're all the way down to
negative contradiction Kujo patterns
right so we're borrowing out inequality
language to help my state something
concrete about these relations okay
let's keep punching for another one look
it y equals we were just looking in the
quiz has been launched like you won't
required to draw any of them by the end
of our to you hopefully do recall you're
only going to be this slightly axis
because how would you describe it what
does it look like that's down here is or
which corner this is the fourth quadrant
okay and then it's that's a pretty steep
and then just slows down like that right
and this is actually important I said
don't worry about interest ecology but
there's an important detail that we need
to note here where is the grass starts
horizontally when's it start
now a bit of a trick question because
there is actually no place where it
starts there's no x value that you can
say on the right of this I start with
this value and no course not because you
can always find a closer one right so in
other words this is x equals zero that's
the asymptote that's the corner because
when I think of that domain just like
this isn't then sort of a restriction
but didnít restriction X is going to be
gotta be positive right Kadri positive
what about range it could go anywhere
try to solve that to this situation up
here so why I can take on any real value
you like okay I've got our two more you
know how to be good
ah actually yeah yeah now though this is
one we just alluded to about ten minutes
ago
what is see your circle
that's a pretty ugly is a total place
you get the idea
it's certainly enough to be able to say
what the domain is where the way this
between negative one and one it
inclusive because you actually can't go
the radius is one so you can go all the
way up and reach one again it's the same
plus 4y instead of 4x okay now I'm just
lucky I've got enough space to fit one
more and that's rather than get she has
and finish the table just creeping what
I'm going to put on here again is a
relation you've seen before but we've
never thought about it through this lens
this is an a what's a call this is the
high total right so again
enjoy your axes you need to have the
whole thing there is that shape now this
was the interesting just like before
because they are important to the
answering this question I looked at the
asymptotes like you there are two what
are they are got X equal zero and y was
here good now this person a little bit
of a problem for us or a challenge at
least for how we state the donated range
let's just figure out the one-time
donate can I say X is all real values I
can treat it is all real values because
there's one particular value for x that
I can take on Mabry x equals zero so one
of the ways you can say this is all real
9news accepts x equals zero that's fine
okay I can do a math although a lot of
people I mean when you look at that
sentence a lot of people please their
rabbit attempted to say X
card equals zero now you tell me why is
that not the domain look on the body and
look at what you've written
why is that not the domain the domain
names were the domain is where is the
best is this where is the relation
defined you said where it's not defined
right so if someone asks you someone
asked me hey what's your favorite food
and I say I hate you because I if you
don't know anything lucky do because I
bruise it
that smells like something died and if
you hit someone with it they probably
died okay I have an answer the question
right if you also like the favorite food
is you expected to say my favorite food
is pizza chocolate whatever you don't
expect her to tell you what your
favorite food is it okay this is what
the domain is the opposite then it do
not say that okay if you prefer not to
say that sentence for which I don't
there is a symbolic way you can write
this you can say look a little over
letter right X can take on any value
less than Europe June notice that for
the left of your arms five to the right
zero I can also take on any back all
right
I'm using this the Equality notation
that I've had before this here is about
the fast that you can probably share
okay so I encourage you to write that
way but either of those ways are fine
see you right now
greater than there are you is your
message right answer that question no
you cannot
they're of you I need thinking of this
you want to combine that into one don't
you yeah ah like that yeah yeah what
you're suggesting no way one of those
rope there wait on this one
oh yeah it doesn't matter is that we
just again I'm gonna throw this terrific
class what do you think of that
okay let me give you two reasons why my
answer is knowledge okay in case no
surprise to you but I don't want you to
rise away number one number one what
does that mean like seriously like that
just exhausting book abuses okay this is
your assignment
so number one is just unclear it's uncle
ah okay secondly give my bigger beads
with it okay Molly when you see
something like this you're clearly
borrowing from this language aren't you
right and we try to do it quickly as
possible I guess this is mathematician
thing this because even a mathematician
who love accepted a fact they don't
because that language is boring from the
idea of one continuous interval from
here to here here's where I start here's
where I end this is the exact opposite
of that this is actually a discontinuous
interval it's the whole point is that
there's a break in there it's not one
thing it's two things right
so therefore number one I think it's
confusing number two it doesn't clearly
communicate what it's trying to talk
about which is two separate things
that's specifically cannot touch rather
than I'm trying to strain it into
notation to indicate to the beyond so
tell me how to write the range
it's just like this right but with one
where you can also say ballroom
alternatively you can take all real
values except y equals zero and that one